como producto del acuerdo tras meses de
discusión el proyecto de ley ocupa más
de 5.500 páginas después de alcanzar un
pacto el domingo pasa al congreso donde
el senado le dio el visto bueno horas
después de que lo hiciera la cámara baja
habiendo alcanzado el umbral de 60 votos
se aprueba la moción y yo los 892 mil
millones de dólares del paquete parte de
una ley de gasto federal más amplia
proporcionarán los tan necesitados
salvavidas financieros a muchas familias
y negocios este incluye pagos en
efectivo de 600 dólares a muchos
estadounidenses y un bonos de desempleo
de 300 dólares semanales los pagos
directos suman 268 mil millones otros
284 mil millones se destinarán a los
pequeños negocios bajo el programa de
protección de pagos 70.000 millones de
dólares se han remitido a la
distribución de la vacuna al rastreo y
pruebas de kobe 19 algunos millones más
irán para cupones de comida y asisten
de alquiler
millones de estadounidenses han esperado
por algún tipo de alivio mucho tiempo
muchos han perdido sus trabajos y están
fuera de sus casas esto ha sido muy mal
manejado no sabemos cómo terminará han
habido muchas idas y venidas mucho
politiqueo yo pienso que el público
estadounidense está harto en conjunto
la ley de gasto de 23 billones de
dólares financiará al gobierno hasta
septiembre